welcome everybody thank you for coming
today tonight we're here to kind of talk
about a kind of combined a super use
case I'm trying to show one possible end
to end and use that as a excuse to talk
about the compositing of different
pieces and tools that are available to
us and the improvement of the tooling
landscape around doing machine learning
firstly I'd like to thank you guy and
beneath in particular for their help in
putting this together the code that
we're gonna have step through today
definitely had some challenges and bumps
along the way and will be kind of
talking through some of those points as
well and of course the cloud developer
relations team thanks to them for their
continued support of this and and other
efforts to engage with the community and
gather your feedback quick check can you
hear me okay on the mic awesome oh god
I've got a little so so yeah it feels
like it's like only sort of picking me
up sometimes so I'll try to shout where
possible as well okay so we wanted to
show a couple of things and then we got
a couple more things and then the title
got really long and we cut it down some
and that's the way I know it with it's
it's a bit of a mouthful there's a lot
of things in there we really wanted to
capture what we were trying to show and
not leave anything out we ended up
leaving a few things out but not
everything so that's what we got we're
gonna but the title is pretty
descriptive you know we're going to go
on cattle so who's heard of cattle
cattle calm it's the data science
platform community website you can run
code on there you there's the
competitions there's forums and we're
gonna use Karis on cattle right and
we're gonna use the GPU is that carol
has yes Cagle also has free GPUs these
so that's fun and train up a modeling
Harris but then convert that model and
export it to be suitable for running on
cloud ml engine so you can scale
your predictions and serve them broadly
and so that's a whole kind of process
and so hooking that entire workflow up
and then actually calling that endpoint
that rest endpoint with new previously
unseen data that end-to-end workflow is
kind of what we're aiming to achieve
today so we in the description kind of
said that this could be viewed as a
pseudo workshop I'll step through all
the code on screen as well but if you
want to you know log into or create a
tactical account all you need is an
email you can do that it's free of
course and if you already have or you
have a cloud account set up and you can
kind of get that ready at some point
there will be a link with TIPA TIPA code
that will be kind of playing with today
so of course this is a what did we call
it not the cloudy I huddle the Google AI
huddle and we know going into this for
the most part I'm going to make some
broad general assumptions around base
knowledge around machine learning and so
I'm just gonna throw this slide up here
as kind of a level set of saying you
know my short a suite definition of
machine learning is busy just
programming with data more or less right
like if you're stripping with as many
details as you can and try to make
something that's shorter than the title
of this talk this is kind of what you
end up with and our plan in more
concrete detail around what we kind of
looked at earlier is we'll grab the data
and we'll talk about what data set we're
gonna use now we're going to do some
fiddling with the data and we'll do some
more fiddling with the data and then
we'll create our model we'll do training
evaluation oftentimes after doing that
you kind of go back and have to revisit
other steps and then there's some more
right there's oh yes and we should turn
on our GPUs at that point and we'll
convert that model from Charis to a
tensor flow estimator which can then be
exported to a save model which
and then the uploaded to Google Cloud
storage then we can create a model
version on machine learning engine and
then we can make a prediction so it's
it's definitely a long kind of workflow
right and so this is intentional in that
I wanted to highlight the fact that
while there are a lot of tools out there
there are ways to get them to fit
together some ways are easier than
others some ways are harder than others
but increasingly the compatibility
surface between different tools
different products are growing every day
and so I think while we pass through
this phase where you know not everything
is going to be super SuperDuper easy you
kind of have to embrace multi you know
different tools different environments
and try to get them to fit together even
if you have to kind of shave the corner
off of one piece to get it to kind of
fit together with the other so the data
set who's heard of the EM this data set
yes so I figured we would do something a
little more interesting than this but
only a little bit more interesting it's
called EMS it's the extended endless
data set it comes from to us from the
same National National Institute of
Standards and Technology but we get some
letters write better than just ten
digits we have some letters and not only
lowercase we'll also uppercase letters
yeah but mom more notably is the fact
that we are you know it's briefing
across 47 classes and of course the
format is also very similar it's still M
NIST it's still 28 by 28 grayscale
images so on one hand it's still that
same sort of stuff probably hand yeah
something less boring than 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 and moreover the kind of
differences between the capital letters
and lowercase letters can make for some
interesting interactions right you'll
notice that there's only 11 letters that
are different enough between their upper
and lowercase representations for it to
like really count like the letter X is
not gonna
up and you don't make us figure out is
this the lowercase X or an uppercase X
apparently everyone's handwriting is too
bad for there to be any distinguish so
that's our data set um let's talk
briefly about libraries right we're
gonna use cast a and caris now is
integrated as part of tensor flow and so
tensor flow has all of these layers of
its library as the low level stuff where
can run on all sorts of platforms and
then there's the Python front-end which
is still kind of testable core and still
relatively low-level and then you have
the layers which is similar to the
Charis layers if you've used that which
allows you to construct your model layer
by layer and it's still kind of
low-level it's your hybrid staff call it
and then above that you have this
abstraction layer where you can
basically it manages a lot of the
training cycle a takes care of gives you
some pre-canned models things like that
and that's kind of where we'll be
operating at but on the Charis side of
things so we'll build a custom model and
use carrots to do it but then we'll
convert that Kerris model that trained
carrots model to a tensor flow estimator
and the current only a good reason to do
that in our particular case is
especially since we're training and
entangle is that we need to export it to
a tension flow estimator but why do we
need to do that is because we need to
put it on cloud ml engine which at for
now at least only accepts tensorflow
save model formats so that kind of
forces our hand there now the typical
reason you would export a Karass model
at least convert a caracal to an
estimator is for the ability to do
better distributed training so typically
you would if you were to use them
together you would construct a Karass
model but then instead of training it
using carrots you would convert it to
tensor flow estimator and training as
trained it has a tangible estimator
because then you get distribution
and GPU kind of scaling for free in
terms of there's no additional work so
that's kind of the typical kind of
thinking there in this particular case
we're going to still continue training
it on the carrots path and have a
trained Karis model that they then take
it through all the rigors of exporting
question yes yeah so the question is
about you know what happens when you
have data that's bigger than memory
that's not quote unquote included with
the library right so in this case
eeehm this I'm not using the one that's
included with the library so we actually
see that we'll see we will use a
generator will flow the data from
directories and so yeah I'll get right
to that awesome
were there any other questions before I
continue cool
and then you got one more slide here
just as a side note that there's also
canned estimators that are kind of also
they take care of even more things for
you and you don't have to like really
manage a lot of the underlying stuff so
that's of less interest in this
particular use case okay so Karis and as
of 1.8 1.7 I showed up inside tensorflow
as TF Kerris and you can pull it in you
know if you have tensorflow installed
carrots that's already there and using
the carrots that's inside of tensorflow
it gives you access to everything that
Kerris has with the addition of those
carrots model to estimator conversion
tools and some of the underlying
implementation is different but the
interface or the API abstraction layers
are difficult yeah go ahead
using cares I didn't know right so the
the Charis that's in tensorflow is you
know kind of line for line or at least
like the api all the calls you can make
for carers are there it's strictly a
superset so the stuff in tensorflow is
just terrace and a little something
extra basically so you can you know the
ideal is you can take your cares code
your existing Kerris code change that
import - you know import tensorflow and
from tencel import carrots and be done
you know so so it's that degree of
guarantee in terms of identical api all
right so the notebook is on cattle and
if you want to type the long URL you can
type the shorter URL that's still kind
of long and it's this whole pattern long
titles long URLs so apologies for that
in advance and then I guess we'll you
know the my goal is to spend the
majority of the time today kind of
actually going through the code and
talking about that and answering your
questions I kind of be able to engage in
a discussion there all right oh yes a
question before we go that's only if you
want to deploy that model right so and
we'll say by and large these steps have
been mostly automated so once you get it
the pipeline set up it's just they're
just running code so it's not like
actual work at that point but there's
some set up okay so if you went to that
URL this should be what you see I have
failed on my Biblica for so it wouldn't
be the first time then it went to the
wrong place but I can find my mouse okay
so one of the neat things about carrots
for those of
you aren't as familiar with it is that
it's go yeah go ahead yes thank you for
reminding me
we'll play with this size for now if we
need to shrink it temporarily later if
things get too long
flying off the page we can do that so
one of the neat things about the tackle
that I personally like is that when you
put up a notebook right
it kind of they got around the problem
of Jupiter notebooks being kind of
unreproducible in that you can run
Jupiter notebook cells in whatever order
you want and then when you give it to
someone else you know if you weren't
careful about making sure you ran
everything from top to bottom in order
with no repeats and you know did a
little test we cleared everything and
started over like okay it all works then
you could really you know hand someone a
notebook that doesn't really work or
they can't reproduce and so with the way
kaggle you know forces your workflow
you're editing the notebook and then you
hit commit and run and it commits
notebook like get stylin saves your
versioning but then it runs that
notebook in a separate virtual machine
clean environment top-to-bottom one cell
at a time in order and so it ensures
that you know when someone else takes
your code and tries to do something with
it actually does the thing that's
expecting so at the top here it's just
the imports from tensor flow import
Kerris as promised and some plotting
numpy pandas the usual goodness the
other piece that is useful here as the
woman in the front mentioned with the
e/m NIST data set is you know I'm
writing running this notebook from the
Charis data set itself right so assuming
that the Wi-Fi holds up and I haven't
randomly broken the cattle website this
website will eventually load the data
set that would do oh yeah we did that so
the data set you know lives as a bunch
of different files and there's
information about it but basically
it's in this directory relative to the
position of the notebook so I go and I
set this path and I can read in our
training and test data there's the data
set it stuff is actually organized by a
bunch of different kind of groupings
there's kind of this node balance data
set which is meant to be the most
applicable in general and these are kind
of the stats around how many examples
there are and you have there 47 classes
but there's also a bunch of other ones
that are split differently and some of
them are significantly larger or smaller
and you can you know this is from the
paper from when they released the data
set the one we're using is this first
one which is balanced across letters and
numbers and so it's kind of nice to work
with 3,000 of each and the other ones
are kind of all over the place but it's
more something that more closely
resembles essentially the raw data that
they had and they didn't normalize as
much okay so yeah well we'll go through
this early part pretty straightforward
right you load the data you read it in
take a peek it's what you expect
catechol has a tendency to load
everything in CSV is obviously you do
not have to store all your data as CS
B's but lots of zeros and the first
column is that label so here it really
illustrates the importance of like whoa
what's 45 means it took me a while to
figure out right and we saw it in the
slides but this could there's a snapping
where there's you gotta get these
letters and numbers in the right order
so that when you look it up later it
actually works so like if you get a
number up here that's 34 you know I can
just index into that string and now I
know it's a Y so that's kind of how I
got around that problem and we can see
here our training data is 112 thousand
rows just as we expected from where is
it downstate is it
okay so well text got bigger yeah free
size boost now one of the things about
this dish is that the for whatever
reason the way they stored this data
right it's flat
all right it's a CSV each row is one
letter or number
we need to recombine them into a 28 by
28 image and the standard way of kind of
that when you do a standard reshape it
actually ends up with something that is
transposed and doesn't isn't a number so
that supposed to be okay as FY in case
it wasn't clear not pi okay and it's
because they're transpose so you want it
to look like that and so this
illustrates you know this is a good
opportunity for us to illustrate a
little bit of pre-processing you know
I'm just basically pulling out the data
reshaping it and then calling numpy dot
transpose and flipping the two axes the
zeroeth and first ax is to be first in
0th and that that gives us our flipped
result so we'll have to you know do that
every time we want to show the image so
I've made a little function to help us
do that so now you don't have to write
that yourself the other piece of it is
understanding like what we said earlier
that the class number the class label
right class 10 is actually a capital A
and so when I'm naming these you know
you do the various lookups that you need
to do in order to obtain both the index
of the label as well as the letter it
ordinal number corresponds to so that
all kind of comes together as one
function you know we do our transpose
and this is kind of my pre-processing
function basically whenever I want to
load the data set from the file name to
something that we can use this is kind
of what I'm doing right in the file and
then here I'm just setting some values
in terms of the dimensions of image I
could just skip that and just use
hard-coded values but and then we have
our transpose here the transpose is a
little more involved because when you
actually grab the full data set and not
just one image it's one hundred and
twelve thousand rows
by 768 or 769 right one extra in the
front so we have to just flip the middle
to right because the first one is the
batch size so that's one hundred and
twelve thousand eight hundred and the
last one is the dimensionality in this
case one and so we switch them so
instead of being 0 1 2 or 3 it's 0 2 1 3
and then the final thing is just kind of
a bookkeeping or yeah a step to switch
our labels to one hot encoded just for
the Charis model to be able to read that
in properly so that changes it from
being a 1 2 3 4 all the way to 46 0
through 46 to being an array of 46
values one of which is a 1 and the
others are 0 the index of which
corresponds to the value oh yes and
because these are images the number of
times I have forgotten to divide by 255
for grayscale images and then
subsequently gotten terrible results and
then went on Google and Stack Overflow
and it's like well you know predictions
are crazy it's a there's no result on
the internet that actually tells you
like if you're training and you're you
know predictions are wildly nuts you
can't figure it out you probably forgot
to divide by 255 so there you have it
now it's on the Internet
let's see yes no we got to make our
model so looking back at our road map
our road map is a far way back we got
the data we did some adjustments some
more adjustments now we got to create
our model architecture so in Karis
mama'll creation is relatively
straightforward some of you would agree
something you would disagree but we can
set it up here I'm building a
convolutional net work just to take
advantage of the fact that we'll have a
GPU in play so may as well had it do
something useful rather than just the
own training a crappy Network and it's
given that we have 47 classes it's
possible that if I just did a fully
connected deep network it might not
actually
no well right so and then we have our
you know the first convolutional layer i
just chose some numbers I tried to keep
it small to make sure you know
especially as I'm iterating it made it
allowed it to train a little faster I'm
doing what am i doing 12 18 24 depth
filters 5 by 5 3 by 3 and 2 by 2 kernels
going through and just standard rail ooh
activations with some dropouts in the
middle yeah I'll pause here for
questions about model or architecture
where is this pretty run-of-the-mill for
folks here so ok so the question is am I
using tensor flow I'm using Karis inside
tensor flow so I'm using Karis in terms
of my syntax I'm using the Karis API to
construct the model and you know in as
for as for all practical considerations
I am using carrots you know after I
create this model you'll see here I can
call ma summary and it prints out
exactly as it would if you were using
Karis right and you know after you train
a model like this if you were to do
model that export and you would get a
dot h5 file or sorry it's not safe right
it's the exact same behavior to a team
so yeah then yeah yeah
is that sorry is there a logic behind
why I chose 0.5 is to drop out I decided
to go with the aggressive drop out to
see what happened I think what happened
was I originally had much larger
convolutional layers and so I was trying
to punish it a little more but then I
Shrunk it and forgot to lower the
dropout so this isn't meant to be a kind
of state of the art model it's not kind
of I'm not mimicking any particular
paper or anything like that this is
literally I just kind of back of the
envelope kind of spit bolts on numbers
out the idea here is to demonstrate the
workflow right now piecing together the
tooling not so much demonstrate a you
know state of the art convolutional
network yeah but the good news is you
know if you have a Karass model that is
really good you can literally just drop
it in the cell and everything else had
just worked which is kind of nice at
some point I was debugging and it was
having trouble getting the shapes and
stuff so I made a little thing to print
out all the shapes as lists but you know
these numbers correspond exactly to the
numbers you see in the summary so
there's not a super high yield use case
here but there you have it you can get
all the shapes at every layer all right
let's train it up so training as we
alluded to earlier we're gonna use a
generator and in particular I have a
couple of options here for you
especially if you take this notebook and
go and do stuff with it we're just good
I just ran the vanilla version but I
actually brought the code for the other
pieces as well there's the standard
image data generator and there's also a
version with augmentation so if you pass
in a bunch of arguments I'm gonna make
this smaller by a little bit just so we
can see the arguments more easily and
doesn't like newline itself to death you
know the standard one I'm just saying
just train it give a 20% 80% validation
split of the training data whereas but
this one you can have it alter the image
right because they are images and
because we reshaped it at the top rather
than passing them in as arrays of 768 we
actually passing in 28 by 28 images so
we can pass on all this stuff around
shifting the image around as well as
rotation zoom and sharing of the image
the tweak and so that sort of stuff can
help you know introduce more variety
into your data set if your data set
isn't super large in this case I have
112 thousand examples I figured that's
probably okay for now and so I opted to
just use the normal data generator but
yeah I thought this might be handy so I
left it or left in here and so we pull
out our two generators so we call the
generator dot flow and get our training
of validation generators and pass that
in to do modeled fit underscore
generator and know for a while I was
doing tiny pox tiny box does work pretty
well here in terms of it gets much
further along the sixth or tenth epoch
do matter I just made it 5-4 for a while
I probably forgot to change it back
because it just runs faster right and so
when I was testing I didn't want to have
it run forever so you know with five a
pox we got to 71% with five more we're
closing in on 80 and for this being kind
of a back-of-the-envelope random network
it's not the worst that's of course
thank you as you mentioned certainly not
not the best network in the world and
it's certainly not you know trained to
any you know crazy degree either so so
yeah at this point we have a trained
model right and then we can call
evaluate and passing our test data
generator that we made your evaluation
I'm always impressed at how concise that
can be right it's like very similar to
the training code in that we load in the
data the same way just passing the test
data path instead of the Train data path
and then the data generator is is very
straight forward to calling there's not
much in the way of arguments since when
you do a validation you will need to
pass through the data set one time
instead of kind of looping it over and
over and over the numbers that are
coming out here the first number is the
loss and the second number is the
accuracy so on our test dataset we're
getting about 77% which you know it's
kind of like a yeah not the worst for
for being kind of written there's some
numbers together
like I'll take it let's see yeah and
then just a brief look at some
predictions here's one such example this
is the letter D in case it wasn't clear
this sounds like an upside-down P and
when we load it in
what's all right this one I think I
might've just been visualizing and then
oh I decided to instead of trying to
pick numbers myself I just picked 10
random ones these are the 10 that
Hampton happen to run so the predictions
are on the first row and the labels are
in the second the correct label right so
you can see we got some wrong we got
most of them right we got that one wrong
we got that one too that it's the same
one I got wrong look at that so whatever
41 is this G it keeps thinking that
whatever 44 is is actually G so if 41 is
G you try to give a C D F G H I J so J's
and G's you can see how that might look
similar and for a lowly trained CNN
model it might struggle in that
department here's an N for those who
were wondering what then it looked like
it kind of was like a upside down in for
some reason but some more letters
anyways so that's prediction so that so
far everything we see it is kind of your
standard Kerris stuff right there's
nothing that we've really looked at that
super wacky or you know aside from the
import or from tensor flow in for
carrots everything else you know you
just so far could have just been a how
to train a convolutional network using
carrots so let's see if we move on from
the kind of creating model training and
such we get to the kind of some of the
interesting pieces here so Karis the
estimator so this is one of the pieces
that were added to Karis in the version
that's in side of tensorflow so normal
Karis does not have a dot estimator
module and so you have this estimator
model to estimator basically it's a
conversion function a utility function
that will take your Karis model and you
know right now I have the model as
a Python pointer right I just I had that
in a variable you could also if you had
a Karass model that had been previously
exported there's a different argument i
think as i Kerris directory or something
you can pass in or the file name you can
pass in the exported file directly you
wouldn't have to load it first and then
put it in it'll take care of that for
you and so you could also you know get a
model that's somewhere else is giving
you or saying like hey you know i got
this thing if you want to try it out
you're like oh i want to know do XYZ but
use test for estimators go for and so
then once it's once you have the model
right the estimator does need a place to
live so this model directory is the
directory for the estimator model not
the directory for the Charis model so
that's why i try to you know give it a
good name like estimator model so it
wouldn't get confused and the only other
side note i would give here is that when
you use this if you if you were to use
this to convert to an estimator and then
actually do more training on it which we
could but we're not going to in this
case the input functions that you use
need to have kind of a name for what to
call the I forget what the proper term
but basically there's the keys to the
dictionary of inputs and that key is con
to D input in this case so you grab it
from the marled input names that's
coming from the Charis model because you
couldn't explicitly set it because it
was built from Charis Charis sets it for
you so next we're going to take that
tensorflow estimator right estimator
model and now we need to export it as a
file so to do that it's a little bit
more involved because what we're going
to do is we're going to set it up so
that we can lead in JPEGs and PNG images
directly rather than reading in a row of
a CSV file because that's not an image
right we built to CNN these are supposed
to handwritten letters and numbers so
you know when you're actually if you
were to imagine writing a production
service which accepted you
had to do this task wouldn't you be
sending images right and encoded over
the wire and not an array of numbers
encoded as you know an array with commas
between like it would just be terribly
size inefficient so you would encode it
using you know pay 64 on a jpg or pay 64
on a PNG send that over the wire and so
to take that and then re munge it back
to a bunch of you know a long array of
numbers it just manually no less just
doesn't feel right
and so what I recommend here doing is no
tensorflow has a number of utilities to
help us create kind of this serving
input function so the inputs to the
model when it's serving predictions can
be different can have kind of a
different head then what is used when
we're doing training so in our case we
did training in Karis anyway so that's
kind of like done we're set and what I'm
doing here I'll kind of try to walk
through this as clearly as possible
because it is kind of easy to get lost
is we use some raw tensorflow pieces
here to get this done so the first piece
is a tensorflow placeholder a
placeholder is basically what it sounds
like
it holds the place for where data will
come in so this is where the binary
image the sixth base64 encoded byte
string will land so it's a string and it
is zero dimensions and so we're calling
this input pH pH is short for place
holder here and what we're gonna do with
that is we're going to call TF decode
images and what that does is it will
take a image and decode it into in this
case unsigned int eight array of numpy
array a tensor of unsigned int eight and
so there's a couple of things happening
here but at the core of it this is this
is what we is notable right we're saying
from here decode this and what we're
calling to make that happen is nap so
we're going to use map to map decode
onto whatever the input is falling into
the input
holder decode image however takes as a
default argument channels is 3 it's
expecting a color image but our images
are grayscale there's only one channel
and so because this argument here the
first argument of map is a function not
a function call I'm using the tenth
Python func tools right to do a wrap
around it and it's same essentially a
lambda where I just set the channels to
one so now when I when it calls this
channels will be set to 1 by default so
it's a little bit convoluted I probably
could have broken that out into a
separate line what I just highlighted
and just called that like no custom
decode image right and so we say map
function or decode image onto input
placeholder and the output type is
unsigned int 8 and then we're gonna cast
that because the defaults are this and
we do want it to be used at interval
cast to float 32 and then of course I
almost forgot to do this divided by 255
all right so that's kind of our integer
so we've transformed our input right
which was just the placeholder because
we don't know what's coming in yet into
a a grayscale image that was divided by
255 the final thing we need to do is
that to know that decode image actually
is smart and knows the dimensions of an
image coming in and so the image that it
spits out or the the 2d array that spits
out will be those dimensions and because
of that we do not know at compile time
so to speak what the dimensions of an
image will be because that happens at
runtime
this runs into a problem later on where
when the model tries to export it says I
don't know what dimensions you're going
to use and so that's why we need this
final line where we set the shape this
isn't explicitly changing the image it's
more of you think of it as like an
annotation it's kind of a let me give
you some more information some more
details
it's like metadata and tag it as 9 which
is the batch size but you can pass in 3
images you can pass in 70 images one
image whatever and then it's been a 28
by 28
one because we have one channel
greyscale and then what we're gonna do
right we have input placeholder and we
have images those are our two things and
we want to use that here we have images
and input placeholder we're going to use
these two as arguments to the serving
input receiver and this is a wrapper
utility function that would generate
what we need to tack on to the top of
our model to use as an input function
for serving predictions and so I'm
choosing to use the model name the model
input name that come to the underscore
input and the second argument I would
recommend using plates and we'll see why
but just believe me for now that will
use bytes as the argument but you you
could theoretically change it but if you
do change it it should end in underscore
bytes so bytes is fine and then what we
pass in here is images and the
placeholder so basically it's saying
this is the first argument is what will
be going into the model and the the
second argument is what is coming in at
the top before that right the
placeholder and then all this code maps
the two together above it so that's a
serving input function this is probably
like the most in-depth I've ever tried
to explain it's so many things going on
it's hard to get right so hopefully if
you have a use case similar to this you
can take this code and just largely use
it as is so the step you get after that
is a lot more straightforward because we
did all the work
you call export save model on our
estimator and we pass in Wow making a
bigger B the bigger we pass in a
directory I just say this is make a
folder file export to stick it in and
pass in that function that we spend all
that time kind of working through and I
just print out the export path to take a
glance at it so this is a you know order
of a generated time stamp and that's why
I like to put in a subdirectory
otherwise you're just gonna get a bunch
of these at the top level it's just a
mess I also included the Charis exports
just for fun
and so we saved the you know the carrots
model using the separated ways the json
and h5 weights and model structure as
well as the full model weights and
structured together and so now when i do
OS what we see here is we have our
export folder that had all that stuff we
have our full model from Charis we have
our model dot v HH 5 and model dot JSON
and we have our estimator model which is
also a folder which contains two check
points that you could if you wanted to
take and train further in tensor flow so
that's kind of the training evaluation
conversion export workflow i also
included yeah the estimator model folder
is yeah yeah the checkpoints only
contain weights right yeah and i just
have a simple plot for accuracy which is
pretty useless here because we did only
for epochs and but you can see how if i
kept ready would actually improve like
we're not really done training yet but
it's more of a placeholder for if you
take this and do more interesting stuff
with it and i have you have a little
chart that you can use loss is the same
way and we're going to pause here and
we'll come back to this notebook and do
the rest of it once we have a use for it
uh shortly so let me show you the output
so as promised there's a bunch of
outputs some of these outputs we haven't
seen yet because i create them later but
basically in the export folder there is
yes save model dot PB and our two
variables you know those are the weights
so this will come out as see here don't
mind the random there we go all right
downloads
no way to make this bigger though where
is there nope no way to make this bigger
so this is you know when you click on
the model and you hit download all you
guys if and you unzip it and you get
this and then you have things like your
state law pp and variables and so you
can just take this entire folder and
upload it to a bucket on google cloud so
in my case I've created a folder here
called DM mist underscore Karis 2tf
carries the tensorflow
and then inside that folder I've been
wow this is a terrible zoom experience
and inside that folder I've created you
know a couple versions because this has
gone through several cycles the v3 ones
seem to work you have our thing and our
baby and our variables and so when we
want to create a new model with cloud ml
engine what that looks like is you go to
a new engine and you go to models and
you can click create model and when you
sync create model really it's just a
wrapper it's literally a name and a
description and nothing else so say I
call it something like this
and you know hey I created a model right
so is here and there's nothing in here
right there's no versions so we need to
create a version to actually do
something with it so when we create a
version we click create version and we
can give it a name this name is
permanent within that version of course
you can delete the version and make a
new one and stuff but it does need to be
unique within a given model so let's
call this you know it'd be the first
version or V 1 or V point one
[Applause]
and there's a runtime selection here
cloud ml engine maps to a couple of
different runtimes these remote runtimes
have behind them different versions of
tensorflow different versions of the
various other Python libraries that you
might care to use in your Python code I
typically just select the most recent
one because you know I've been using the
most recent version of tensorflow
but there are those who are using for
example test flow 1.0 still right there
using any production and so this
supports kind of compatibility back to
there's a whole list of the different
versions of what libraries are in each
one I would recommend selecting it
manually because it will default you to
1.0 and then you will be sad so if we
copy this out and we take this directory
alright so what it wants is a directory
whoops I didn't want a definition of it
a directory of where these files live
and so you'll notice here that because
tensorflow exports the models not as a
single file but as a folder of various
things you want to always make sure
there's a wrapping folder for it
otherwise it can get well necie right so
it needs to be a folder with nothing but
these two files and you also notice that
as I highlight this right this is
basically what you need to paste in this
is the bucket name and then these are
the folders in the path to it you can
hit browse and you know navigate your
way there but if you already have this
open you just you just finished
uploading the files and stuff you know
may as well just copy it over however
when I do that I am greatly saddened
because it says folder not available and
the reason for that and I say reason but
I say that in a very weak sense of the
word reason is that it is looking for a
folder and the UI argues that a folder
must always end in a trailing slash
so I will now press slash
so this is my note to the UI team that
is building this and so if they had a
slash here we could just copy paste that
over right then we wouldn't need you to
worry about it so that's my latest gripe
so remember the trailing slash and you
will not be disappointed or you can use
the Browse thing and your select they're
all populated for you but it'll create
its version it'll do its thing all of
the operations that we're doing on the
UI right now are accessible via API and
command line so you can use command line
to do this script out on - or you can
call it through the python api the ruby
api that go api job whatever you want
and automated using that so there's a
lot of options there you can use the api
is to create versions create models
delete them edit them change the name
well you can't trace the names a name is
permanent but you can delete it and
create a new one and you can do all
those things so you can you know
automate the whole process you can add
testing and various kind of pipeline
it's almost like CIC day before machine
learning to that to that effect
so it's gonna create its thing yeah it's
gonna take a while because sometimes it
takes a while but luckily we created one
earlier and I created one see if score
our models and I call the EMS Cagle I
misspoke Eris and I failed the first
time but third time's the charm and so I
called it v1 v2 v3 the name of the call
is e and this tagil Kerris and my window
is behaving okay find the thing promise
I'll make this bigger
oh this is gonna be really good when I
unplug later if needs to be huge so to
make this call we need to basically did
a bunch of experiments recently okay so
we call it G cloud ml engine predict we
say what model was it right just that
same string name we say what version it
was in our case v3 and then we had to
pass in this input data file so this
brings us back to where we were earlier
I promise we go back to the notebook and
we will where we are so let's go down
past all the stuff we saw earlier and
look at after the graphs as soon as my
computer decides to scroll we're gonna
create some output files for adding some
prediction files for ourselves
I had this originally and a separate
Python script on my local machine then I
realized wait we can just do this in a
notebook and then you all have access to
the code which is great I use the same
call to that whole transpose business
that we did at the beginning to take a
whatever row of data and do the thing
where you know transpose the values then
we can use the pil library pill to pull
out an image render the image from an
array so we originally this array is
actually in 64 and so it will complain
not you so you need to cast as one sign
in 8 but then you have your image and
then I used the same code that we saw
before that I used to label those images
with both the class name the label you
know 47:32 whatever and to figure out
the letter that corresponds to to make a
nice filename for myself so it'll be
class something labeled J or something
like that and we're gonna export one of
them and so that'll give us a PNG right
and so now with that PNG file we need to
base64 encoded and so the steps they
keep coming and so we have our class 19
label J PNG and we're going to encode
that into JSON and call that file class
19 labeled
I thought Jason and so to do that we'll
read in our PNG file and base64-encoded
note that Bay sixty-four encodes in
Python three behaves differently than
Python two and those of you have
experienced that are smiling and nodding
right now on rest assured that the first
time I encountered this I was not
smiling you're nodding it is horrendous
because it comes out as bites and you
know what's not bites strings which is
what you want and you know what else you
can't encode into JSON lights and so you
know you try to call this and it doesn't
work and then you realize all you have
to do is wrap STR around it and it works
or change your environment to Python too
so those are tricks and then so once you
have that you know and you printed a
bunch and you're sure that you're doing
it right and you're like are you can
write it to a file and that's you know
the most straightforward thing ever is
just dump it out to a file and this is
our base 64 encoded letter J I know it
doesn't look super compact but it's much
better than seven hundred and sixty-four
grayscale numbers with commas in between
them and spaces and so that's kind of
the final bit of the story in cattle is
that we're going to use we use the
output abilities of this to kind of
output us our class 19 label JSON JSON
which we can then use when we want to
call our model
yes intently I wonder if our model
finished because then we can actually
call it prove to you all that it worked
so we finished loading it up so let's
see decided to refresh itself so we want
to say
googly-eye huddle is the name of our
wearers I have so many windows okay so
we want to say model name equals
googly-eye huddle version name does
anyone remember the version
I'll have both many mix things so yeah
the old one was v-8 three but we're
tuning to this new model right I don't
actually remember it and no one's
speaking loudly enough first version yes
first underscore version and the data
file already actually have set but I'll
show you this class 19 label JSON and I
do have both the JSON and the other file
here but there you are there's the JSON
we can look at it I guess that's
probably more useful than just seeing it
there's as we expected now what I've
done here is I've wrapped it in two
pieces here one is bytes
remember we said bytes earlier I want to
use bytes in our serving function so
this is the word bytes and maps to that
word so it's kind of a random word you
put whatever you want so you know you
can doesn't really matter but almost all
the samples will use bytes and be 64 so
you need to know there they are inside
which is you know another can sometimes
we'll trip people up at any rate we've
set our values so let's all right I
never actually ran this mine so let's
just run it so this is the command-line
utility that you can use to interact
with Google Cloud and it will come back
with a mess of numbers so this is the
other funny thing about this right it's
like what is all this these are the
probabilities of each of the 47 classes
and so what we really want right it's
like tell me what I really want is
to run Arg max
[Music]
and so we get 19 and if you'll recall
our file was 19 J we can also open and I
think it's a PNG oh good you can't open
it
apparently oh we can pull it up in other
ways oh right it's a tiny J all right
I'm sorry tiny J and then we've had 19
yeah so that's kind of the crazy journey
J for journey yes thank you that it
takes to kind of get from you know
you're taking the data who did all that
stuff to get it set up right and we
train our model which you can train
however you want and then on the flip
side right we did all that and that was
like the first bit and then we spent the
rest of the time hooking everything else
up together
but once we have this hook together
notice that all the pieces are entirely
scriptable and all the almost all the
code was in the cattle kernel right and
so you can imagine where I haven't like
actually deployed this but you can
imagine a situation where you can have
kind of a real real-time ish situation
where you have code commits going in on
one side - you know your training models
you have something coming out and then
you can drop it or folder that gets
picked up and and then all these steps
happen and then at the end of it you
have a deployed model that's ready to
serve one of the things I like about
cloud and all engines kind of prediction
side of things is that as easy as it is
to create that version you know wow it
does feel like we didn't really earn
having a globally
correction eyes model that scales
automatically based on demand is secured
has a REST API for free along with all
the client libraries across all of the
six major languages that Google Cloud
supports it feel like we didn't really
earn that right we just give it a name
point it to a directory and just said
like alright do all the things and those
things are like replicating it across
servers across the world and it's
available now right it's available to be
called at scale and you know from any
device that connects to the internet so
it means you can call it from your
phones
an app can call from IOT devices it
means that you need to get predictions
from your edge piece of edge devices
that are connecting the network you can
do that and obviously from web and
servers and things so wow we're really
far back in the presentation okay go
back okay so yeah we talked about the
tooling yeah we've kind of fit to this
together right there were definitely
some rough edges here and there it's not
a you know one click oh we're done look
at that cuz that would make for a much
less interesting talk but piecing these
pieces together is both you know
can be frustrating but the end result
we're getting to a point where the end
result is oftentimes more valuable and
worth it worth the the pain so to speak
and you know everything gets smoother
and smoother over time and so these this
tooling will get better and better but
in the meantime you can reap the
benefits especially because even though
it's hard to put together initially it
can be set up as a you know reproducibly
deployed pipeline that you can use to
keep pushing out predictions keep
pushing out new models new versions
doing a/b testing things like that and
as more tools come online as you you
know are familiar with all these pieces
you can imagine branching off right it's
like you know you train along you do
this thing you deploy here maybe you
know you're chaining a tensorflow model
and now we're gonna convert your carrots
or you can do the reverse you can you
know instead of try doing it on tackle
maybe you're running a notebook locally
and then you can export do the same sort
of thing so a lot of this knowledge
carries across multiple
kind of disciplines in a way yes
questions so the technique that we're
looking at here is a kind of utility
that's inside of Karis the one that's
inside of tensorflow
so it's specifically a piece added to
Karis to enable the conversion of Karis
models to tensorflow estimators as far
as existing tools I'm not actually
familiar enough with existing tools
around conversion of pi torch models the
potential flow of models I think I saw
something to that effect I'm not sure
about like officially supported tools
though you know like this is an
officially supported converter from
Karis model statistical models and that
that's also part of the appeal of it
like everything I've shown you here
today none of it is kind of some
experimental side project that may or
may not exist next week it's all things
that are have essentially deployable in
production sure
so the question is around if I deploy to
V wine of a model now I want to
fine-tune that model what tools are
available in Google cloud to achieve
that so when you deploy a model that's
kind of you're serving model right we
you saw the code where we called export
and we supply to serving function when
we you call export save model you know
some of the things that's doing
conceptually you can imagine is that the
weights in the model are being frozen
and so where's when you're training you
want to obviously allow the ways to be
updated and when you deploy the model
you just want this model to run as fast
as possible to spit out predictions
right so when you want to do fine-tuning
you should go back to the model you were
training right pick up where you left
off and do your fine-tuning there and so
you can almost think of it it's similar
to kind of developing code when you have
kind of your main trunk of code and then
you have releases right and if you want
to tune your code so to speak you
wouldn't take that release back and
unpackage it and start working from back
source right you wouldn't decompile your
code or anything if you already have
your source code you'll just continue
working on along and later on you know
next week you have another release so
similarly here your training your model
you export it you deploy it you can keep
printing it you can keep tweaking it and
you can deploy another one right and
when you do you could do kind of split a
be testing where you know you you put
some traffic to wine some craft if the
other because when you actually call
these end points as we saw you've
specified not just the model name but
also the version and so you could put
some kind of load balancing or a be
split testing if you wanted on top of
that and say call version this then a
little bit on that just to make sure
that I didn't just break everything by
deploying a new model
so the question is around whether we
support exporting save models to be
deployed on devices aside from cloud
machine learning engine in particular
edge devices so the format of the saved
model of export state model it's a it's
the tensor flow model export format of
choice and from that you can kind of go
in a number of directions it's probably
it's the most versatile so to speak of
the choices in terms of formats and you
can kind of down convert so to speak to
other things so the version we're using
for a cloud ml engine right it's just
directly no further conversion needed
but you can use things like Excel a or
accelerated linear algebra libraries
which is part of test flow and take that
and use that to alter your exported
model in ways that make it more suitable
for running on edge devices that cause
it to shrink the model and things like
that
so the devices are devices that are
coming from sure so you're saying you
want to load your own models onto those
pieces of hardware yes all right now
those devices open for like developers
like there's an SDK - yes okay yeah
that's
but then we may want to explore multiple
devices support acceleration to my
specific
yeah great yeah so yes yeah so talk
oh yeah so make sure you from them yeah
there's a raffle at the end so remember
your numbers separate thing so yeah
you're coming around kind of
architectural specific deployments you
know I think where we're at today would
basically have a situation where when
you export a model to this export sales
model that's like the full it captures
the full richness of your model its
weights its structure or everything
right that's the highest fidelity
version and then typically what happens
is you then start tearing it down for
other architectures you start adjusting
and start you know fiddling with it and
so I I would imagine that at least for
the majority of kind of architectures
we're kind of getting to a point where
especially with the excel a compiler but
it is extensible to make it suitable for
other kinds of architectures so
obviously you don't want to be in the
compiler writing business but the idea
is that others write the the makers of
those chips the makers of those chipsets
can then use that specification and kind
of extend xla to enable these kinds of
conversions so so kind of like a high
point and hub-and-spoke well other
questions yes
five million what new predictions per
day per second like 5 million part of
what unit of time like you are you
saying just the rod amount or the rate
the rate so 5 million in how much time
what a second yeah so what's the current
scale of making predictions with kind of
analogous a lot of it is going to depend
on your model right like the size of the
model the size of those images you're
sending and if there are images the
other piece of it is kind of it will
probably take a second to ramp up
especially you know if you're dumping it
with a lot right so those first couple
might be a little slower but then as it
scales out horizontally and spins up
more servers to respond to the increased
request load you it'll certainly you
know become more and more performant
Robby do you have any comments on kind
of what kind of benchmark testing you've
done in terms of just
back-of-the-envelope performance so the
most important thing is how long each
prediction takes like if it takes a
millisecond obviously we can do a lot
more QPS because that requires fewer
resources and if it takes 10 seconds
then we can do a lot fewer but the
general rule of thumb I would say is I
think you can do about a thousand QPS
with a really simple quota request if
you want to do about 10,000 or above we
most likely can do it but you'll need to
contact us and we'll need to work to
make sure we have enough resources but
we can easily scale above that and
beyond so just contact us if you're
interested oh yeah follow
if you had much more expensive ETL for
training or for prediction oh oh so yeah
I guess that would depend on the domain
right like especially if you're if
you're willing to go out to you know a
separate system to do ETL it sounds like
you're doing batch prediction then not
kind of online responsive prediction but
then you know you can do a fair amount
of detail on tensorflow but yeah if you
if you want to do kind of mass
transformations yeah you should use
whatever tools you're comfortable with
if you want to stay within Google cloud
there's you can run the spark on data
proc and if you're kind of developing a
new set of detail you can also use
things like beam on data flow so there's
a beam as a patchy open source kind of
ETL transformation tool that you can
allows you to use the same source code
to transform both stream and batch data
that's where the name comes from beam is
badge and stream and they and you can
run it on data flow which is kind of
intended to be kind of a next-generation
ETL service where you can just basically
it's sort of like the way I'm engine
works where you can just submit your
code and they're just run you don't have
to think about machines and the size of
the machines and how many machines it's
just here's my beam code here's my data
go make it happen and it paralyzes
everything for you and so that part this
nice the final piece of it would be TF
transform which is the library for doing
you guested transformations
it's based on the beam API so there's a
lot of similarities there which allow
you to kind of carry things over but by
and large you have you know those would
be kind of some of the options in in
that space yeah another
right
so once you've deployed your model like
you saw there you have access to the
batch prediction API which will allow
you to do it's it's throughput optimized
and so you know we don't really talk
about QPS it's more about its it auto
scales to as many workers as you want
and so you could use that in an ETL
pipeline if you're using some
orchestration system like Argo or cloud
composer which is air flow for that type
of thing
there's another option ya know a lot of
options out there for kind of you know
moving data around the exciting part
this is this is why you all came right
you saw the long title and then you were
like wait but I can get a backpack other
questions well while we wait for numbers
that appear well I also recently learned
that if you type into a Google search
random number between x and y like well
random number being 50 and 73 it'll just
return the number for you so don't ask
me why I thought yeah go ahead
none that I know so the question is
around there once you have a model
defined in Paris you know two choices
you can continue and train it in cars or
you can convert it to tensor flow and
train it in tensor flow alright so you
have kind of these parallel pads that
diverge and then we can kind of come
back together and on a local machine is
there any advantage to training on Keros
versus training on a tensor flow
estimator off top my head I can't think
of any in particular but maybe you have
some more extended a so basically
Candice is the official tensor flow
model authoring layer so you want to use
carries two or three architecture the
dispatch and the execution of the model
itself should be done to estimate API
what that means is that your authoring
language now is much less verbose and it
has all the same benefits of tensor flow
because the underlying execution engine
is actually tensorflow so that that was
actually an official thing from from
pencil and that that's why you want to
use the TF Kerris because that's a it's
assumes the open source guess and kind
of the rationale behind have why we
recommend converting to estimator in
general and training on the estimator
it's like well you know I already have a
care of smile why don't I just train it
as it is is if my understanding is
correct more based around the fact that
you know should you want to then move to
a more you know a larger data set a more
you know maybe several GPUs hooked up to
the same machine moving to any you know
any number of cloud environments those
sorts of things then become a lot easier
and becomes basically seamless if you
already have a tensor flow estimator and
there's also certain benefits in terms
of the code the conversion can be made a
little bit easier in certain spots if
you convert it and train it as it is
rather than trying to convert it
afterwards
all reduce so tensor for now has in
contrib a distribution strategy so you
basically and tell tensor for that but
they want to use a yeah P SS or workers
or all reduce ring all reduce which is
much better technique to do distribution
and that you can plug in with the the
estimator very seamlessly so that that's
another benefit of doing that yeah it
seems like the the kind of push is
really around you know can keeping the
Karis ap is kind of clean and readable
and as possible while leveraging the
benefits of kind of estimator
distribution strategies and distribution
technology that's under the hood there
cool any other questions before we move
to random number generator yeah please
this question whether or not it's easier
to develop a prototype
for prototyping I mean a lot of its
going to depend on your use case and the
kind of data that you have you know I
can see the benefits both bite like a
one side Karras has an arguably simpler
API and perhaps fewer kind of concepts
that you have to kind of learn I'm so so
I guess part of it is like the question
of do you already know one of these two
libraries going into it right and so the
there's a different comparison if you
say I know Karis and I know tensorflow
which one should I use versus I don't
know either
which one should I learn right which one
is better which one is faster in those
two use cases they it can kind of lead
to different considerations and then of
course there's the consideration of your
actual data format I think at this point
both libraries are you know reasonably
clean but as praneeth mentioned kind of
going forward the officially kind of
supported and developed and promoted
method of working with tensorflow will
be through Karis especially for the
model authoring step where you construct
the model structure so potential 1.9
just came out a few days ago and it
comes with a total refresh of the
tensorflow website in terms of the
guides the getting started guides they
are now all pivoted to Kharis and eager
mode which we didn't talk about here but
we'll just skip that point
caris so so basically carrots smart
carrots oh yeah
yeah that's about it
okay so yeah yeah yeah so the question
is around kind of the difficulties
behind versioning datasets and
collaboration of training models on
differing versions of those data as well
as collaborating on the source code
itself which which perhaps you know
software engineering has developed more
standards around then for data so I'll
throw a few kind of ideas around here
one is a in addition to the COG
O'Connell's being versioned the datasets
are actually also versioned so you can
create new versions of your dataset and
when you combine that with the notion
that you can have private datasets that
are shared among a selected group of
users then you can fit together a decent
collaboration model in that sense right
because you have version notebooks you
have versions of datasets both with
ability to do access control that being
said the you know obviously Cavill
kernels are not going to kind of serve
all your production needs right it's a
great kind of learning and collaborative
platform but when you when it comes time
to do the deployer model when you're not
just like competing in a competition or
doing something for fun then you kind of
end up having to sometimes looks
elsewhere with you mentioned collab
earlier today and so in collab what's
neat about it right and I forgot to
mention this in the pro/con list by
accident I assure you because it is a
neat feature collab is like Jupiter
notebooks Google Docs tile so and I mean
that in its entirety in particular it
lets you do simultaneous editing just
like in Google Docs so if I'm in the
collab and you're in the collab we are
both running against the same computer
in the backend it's it's like you and I
are sitting side by side at the same
machine but we for some reason have two
monitors and the same file pulled up so
we can look at different
at the same time and it means that we
can put comments in just like in Google
Docs so you can actually add comments to
someone else's collab and say okay you
know I don't think this is quite right
you know maybe you could try this thing
or you could use it to ask questions to
your collaborators right and so there's
a lot of different pieces kind of there
I don't know that there's any good kind
of all the things combined under the Sun
in one you know one package at this
stage I'm sure folks are working to you
know make that happen and get the
advantages of the different tools and
kind of put them in a more unified
manner to a reduce confusion but also
increase the functionality and improve
the workflows around this so yeah I mean
that kind of goes back to the central
point around this you know that the
tooling is kind of still in development
right just across the field in general
right there's new things happening all
the time and for the most part those new
things are better those you know better
things are coming and they're coming out
of rapid rate and you know it's an
exciting time for sure any other you
want to add anything to the tooling and
in a code which was she ate you know
will be available so check out our
googly eye huddle channel I set the
right term on Twitter hashtag slash not
Channel and you know that's where you
know you basically can watch for all our
announcements and content and everything
so we'll be doing that yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you